Taxpayers around the world are giving fossil
fuel producers 5 TRILLION dollars in free
money…
every.
Year.
That’s as much as the Iraq and Afghanistan
wars put together.
This is based on a new study by the International
Monetary Fund, that estimated the amount of
the subsidies to fossil fuel companies.
And five trillion is a lot of money.
The reason they think it’s so much, is because
fossil fuel producers don’t pay to clean
up the air or water.
They don’t have to deal with the medical
costs of air pollutants.
And the researchers bunch all this into subsidies.
Effectively making taxpayers foot the bill
to clean up and pay, just to keep using fossil
fuels.
For example, if a company wants to drill a
well that may not hit oil, the cost is 100-percent
tax deductible; it’s a direct taxpayer subsidy.
But the paper also included the more intangible
costs like climate change effects, the cost
to supply oil vs what consumers pay, and even
deaths from air pollution!
Again, this added up to: Five.
Trillion.
Dollars!
There is a pile of research saying carbon
and particulate-emitting fossil fuels cost
more than you think.
For example, gas in the U.S. is currently
two dollars and forty cents a gallon.
A 2015 study says the true cost, when we add
in the cost of the air pollution from burning
it, is six-twenty a gallon.
Diesel would be even more!
And coal power would add a quarter for every
kilowatt hour.
Calculating these hidden subsidies is not
new; it’s been studied (controversially)
many times.
But it’s important to bring up because,
it doesn’t have to be this way! 139 countries
could be 100% powered by wind, water, and
solar by 2050, says another new study!
The study lead said, “Every country that
we examined has sufficient resources to power
itself.”
Just imagine!
139 countries with 100-percent clean, renewables…
no carbon emissions -- including the US and
China!?
That’s incredible!
Not to mention, we wouldn’t have to pay
pollution subsidies.
So I have to ask, why do we pay all this money
to keep using non-renewable coal and oil?
Do you think we should fund renewables or
stick to what we know with fossil fuels?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments.
And if you want to know which of these fuel
sources are the most efficient, watch this
video here (it might surprise you).
Take a second and subscribe, and if you want
to talk about it, come find me on Twitter,
@tracedominguez.